[Music]
this is Jill Biden this is from Dr Jill
Biden the wife of the president of the
United States from her official Twitter
account uh this is the debut of the
White House Christmas decor and
celebration hold on to your hats
[Music]
folks
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it never ends people that goes on for 87
hours we just clipped it for you all
right you might be watching that going
Dave don't be outraged about this why
you trying to make me Outrage about some
silly little white house thing okay
maybe there was a drag queen in there or
whatever tap dancing's not so terrible
and you'd be right except of course what
did we find out this morning this is
from End wokeness Breaking the group
behind the viral Biden Christmas video
is a radical anti-white group called
dorance dance on the group website they
call for defunding the police abolishing
prisons and even quote Marxist terrorist
Angela Davis the site has an entire
section dedicated to
anti-white literature so regardless of
whether you think it's tacky to have
them tap dancing and the guy dressed as
a woman and all the sort of over-the-top
ridiculousness and that's kind of what's
filled up everything these days
culturally um maybe they could have
found another group the tap dances that
aren't so in lined with Marxist are
there any tap dancing groups that aren't
Marxist Brock you're the tap dancing
specialist here do you know any
non-marxist tap dancing groups you have
to be you oh apparently now you have to
be a Marxist to be a tap dancer well
there you go uh I want to contrast that
to Melania white Melania
white Melania Trump's White Christmas
go
[Music]
Melania White's beautiful Christmas
there you have it anyway it's not tell
to really get your panties in a bunch
other than it does show the kind of
cultural rot that just infected
absolutely
everything